at the very moment he was making the
history no president wants to make 600
miles away from Washington the warmest
of warm welcomes for Donald Trump this
room was his base made flesh and
outwardly at least the president
seemingly untroubled by the votes in
Congress we did nothing wrong we did
nothing wrong and we have tremendous
support in the Republican Party like
we've never had before nobody's ever had
this in the eyes of many here he can do
no wrong bringing up against him
seems pretty bogus I think it's
ridiculous I I feel like it's this man
has done so much for our country I
believe it has emboldened a lot of
people who were not sure where their
loyalties lied they see the unfairness
of this process and you can see
throughout the whole country people are
rallying to our president there's no
escaping what was a defining moment for
this president though that moment of the
actual vote passed without much notice
in the room Trump's defiance far more to
their liking
it's the most obnoxious thing that they
could do in our country I think he's
right on the money I think that they
have no leg to stand on
I think it's a false premises and I
don't think we have anything to worry
about in 2020 I would say the
president's frustrated along with every
American person were frustrated it's a
sham if it was up to the people in this
room Donald Trump would survive
impeachment unscathed
but this was a state he won by eleven
thousand votes out of five and a half
million it shows you the margins and
what's at stake in next November's
election he left them after two hours on
stage with a familiar message and a
country more certain than ever that its
next election will be the real judgment
day on Donald Trump Gregg Milam Sky News
Battle Creek in Michigan